Olha o que me perguntaram. O que pode
causar o uso da vitamina K2, MK7 em
excesso? Sabe aquela história de que se
faz bem, mas ainda é melhor? Pois é,
galera. Hoje vamos bater um papo sobre
um assunto que está pipocando os
consultórios. Será que dá para exagerar
na vitamina K2, MK7? Você que tá aí do
outro lado tomando sua suplementação
direitinho, já se perguntou se existe um
limite, vem comigo que eu vou contar
tudinho que a ciência mais atual tem
para nos ensinar sobre isso. Olha só,
primeiro vamos entender uma parada bem
interessante. A K2 MK7, essa que é a
chamada MENACN 7 que tanto falamos, é
considerada uma das vitaminas mais
seguras que existem. Os estudos mais
recentes de 2024 mostram que ela
praticamente não tem toxicidade
conhecida. Um estudo publicado na
Scientific Reports testou doses
altíssimas em animais, tipo 4500 mg por
kg de peso e não encontrou efeitos
adversos significativos. Para você ter
noção, isso seria como uma pessoa de 70
kg tomar mais de 300 g de C2 por dia.
Loucura, não é? Mas calma lá. Não é
porque ela é segura que podemos sair
tomando qualquer quantidade sem pensar.
A vida real é bem diferente dos estudos
controlados. Então, quando falamos de
doses normais, tipo aquelas entre 100 a
200 microg por dia, que geralmente
recomendamos, estamos numa faixa super
tranquila. Mas quando começamos a
assumir muito essas doses, algumas
coisas interessantes podem acontecer.
Primeiro vamos falar daquele elefante na
sala, a questão da coagulação. Muita
gente acha que vitamina K2 vai engrossar
o sangue formar coágulos. Olha que
curioso, um estudo de 2021 da Holanda
mostrou que a suplementação com K2, MK7
nas doses recomendadas não altera os
fatores de coagulação em pessoas
saudáveis. Ou seja, naquele pessoal que
não tem problema nenhum de saúde, a K2
não mexe com a coagulação do jeito que
muitos imaginam. Agora, se você toma
anticoagulante, especialmente a
varfarina, aí o bicho pega. A interação
entre vitamina K2 e vafarina é real e
pode ser sério. Então, estudos mostram
que doses baixinhas, até mesmo 10 microg
por dia, já podem interferir no efeito
do anticoagulante. É como se a vitamina
K2 e a vafarina estivesse numa queda de
braço constante, uma tentando anular o
efeito da outra. Mas vamos aos sintomas
práticos do excesso quando eles
aparecem. Embora sejam raros, alguns
pacientes relatam desconfortos quando
exageram na dose. O fígado pode ficar
sobrecarregado, processando tanta
vitamina liposolúvel. E aí podem surgir
sintomas como aumento do fígado,
palidez, sudorese, que é a suadeira
aumentada e em alguns casos mais
chatinhos, até falta de arema nas
pálpebras. Mas olha, para isso
acontecer, a pessoa precisa estar
tomando doses bem acima do recomendado e
por muito tempo. Tem uma coisa bem
bacana que descobriram, a fórma natural
da K2, tanto MK4 como MK7, não apresenta
toxicidade significativa, diferentemente
da vitamina K3 sintética, que é a
menadiona, que essa sim pode ser tóxica.
E é por isso que hoje em dia ninguém
toma mais K3 em suplementação humana. E
a natureza é sábia, não é, pessoal?
Agora, um ponto super importante para
quem toma K2 junto com vitamina D3. Essa
dupla dinâmica trabalha junta no
metabolismo do cálcio, mas quando você
exagera na K2 sem equilibrar com a D3,
pode acontecer um desequilíbrio. Então o
cálcio pode começar a ser direcionado
demais pros ossos e faltar em outros
lugares onde também é necessário. É como
se você tivesse um caminhão de mudança
superficiente,
mas que leva tudo para um lugar só,
esquecendo de distribuir direitinho.
Quem precisa ficar mais ligado com as
doses? Primeiro, obviamente, quem usa
anticoagulantes. Segundo, pessoas com
problemas hepáticos, já que o fígado
processa essa vitamina. Terceiro,
gestantes e lactantes, que sempre devem
ajustar as doses com acompanhamento,
porque ainda não temos estudos
conclusivos sobre doses muito altas
nesses grupos. E quarto, pessoas com
distúrbios de coagulação sanguínea que
devem ter um cuidado redobrado. Uma
coisa que pouca gente sabe, a absorção
de K2 pode ser prejudicada se você tomar
doses muito altas de uma vez só. É
melhor dividir em doses menores ao longo
do dia do que tomar uma me dose única. O
intestino tem um limite de quanto
consegue absorver por vez e o excesso
simplesmente vai embora. Então é jogar
dinheiro fora literalmente se você tiver
trabalhando com dose mais alta de K2. E
tem mais, quando você toma dose muito
alta de K2 por muito tempo, pode
acontecer uma regulação negativa dos
receptores e é como se o seu corpo
ficasse preguiçoso e parasse de
responder também à vitamina. Aí quando
você realmente precisa dela, a resposta
não é tão eficiente. É o famoso menos é
mais que a medicina funcional tanto
prega. Agora vamos falar de números
práticos. Mas a maioria dos estudos
mostra benefícios ótimos com dose entre
45 e 200 microg por dia. Acima de 45 mg
por dia, como testado em alguns estudos
japoneses, não mostrou problemas de
coangulação, mas também não mostrou
benefícios adicionais significativos, ou
seja, mas não é melhor. Nesse caso,
pessoal, a mensagem que fica é: "A
vitamina K2, MK7 é extremamente segura
quando usada nas doses recomendadas. 100
a 200 microg por dia, você não erra
nessas doses. Não existe um limite
superior estabelecido oficialmente,
porque a toxicidade é praticamente
inexistente", mas isso não significa que
devemos estar tomando quantidades
absolutas. A sabedoria está no
equilíbrio em entender que nosso corpo
tem limites de absorção e utilização e
que interações medicamentosas existem e
que tê que ser respeitadas. Se você está
na dúvida sobre sua dose ideal, o melhor
é começar baixo e ajustando conforme a
resposta do seu organismo e seus exames
de acompanhamento. E lembra, quem toma
anticoagulante precisa ter uma conversa
séria sobre isso antes de começar a
suplementar K2. A saúde é um
quebra-cabeça complexo e cada peça
precisa se encaixar direitinho para
funcionar bem. Cuide-se com
inteligência, não apenas com entusiasmo.